gas supply issues and what was caused by
uh mechanical issues that were caused by
the storm coming in
and but over the next you know very soon
we will be sending rfis out to each
plant to find out exactly why they went
offline because that's really important
i mean that's fundamentally this is a
this is a if you only have this much
generation
it's available regardless of what the
reason was that's all the load you can
serve
you can't serve more than that so as
generation went from here down to here
for whatever reason
load had to go down there too because
you can't have you can't serve more
just with any kind of product you can't
serve more
uh consumption than what you have
available
resources to serve it if you don't have
enough that you've got a
balance and and this that's that's
that's the hard thing about this is
that that the reason we had to do those
reductions was because that's just all
the supplies that the generators were
making available for us to use
and i'd say just dan used the term rfi
i'll just mention that's a request for
information where we'll send information
requests out to generators on issues
we're investigating
as you know to determine uh root cause
analysis and things like that for
uh for any event
dan if you could scoot into the frame a
little bit more a little bit closer to
bill there you go thank you
um okay the next question is kpr city
uh does erco believe it received an
accurate forecasting can you provide
copies of the notices sent to generators
starting on february 8th
um leslie i'm sure you can arrange to
have copies of
the notice yeah yep uh and an accurate
forecast well the
the weather forecast uh that we were
relying on
um i don't have any reason to believe
was was
inaccurate because the the temperatures
as the week went on last week and all
the weather forecasts just kept
declining
and the expanse of the storm expanded
uh and our meteorologist was telling us
you know probably by midweek last week
you know we haven't seen anything
this strong in a long time and then uh
it just continued the temperatures
continued to drop so
by the end of the week we were running
our
our forecasts ahead for this week and
seeing that you know
as we've said before you know we
expected to be in some sort of rotating
outage
uh monday morning and tuesday morning uh
we've certainly a risk
that we were prepared to manage uh but
it was when we saw the
um you know much larger loss of the
generation that we had that the much
bigger problem
uh uh better uh sunday night monday
morning
uh so i i don't think the the forecast
for the
of the weather was all that off um
i don't think the forecast of the demand
was all that off because we were seeing
extremely high demand
uh and i think we we forecast generation
really by just what generators tell us
you know they can do
what's available on the system uh what
they plan to be running
and uh looking at what they plan to be
running uh
you know they understood there was a big
storm coming and we needed all hands on
deck and all power on the system
and uh that's what they were planning to
provide but the storm came in and
lots of different issues occurred that
have now you know been resolved
so they can be back on the system but
during the period when they had to go
fix those things that you know that was
a central problem
okay the next question does ercot have
any authority over the winterization of
power generation facilities or does that
authority lie with a separate
governing body uh
authority over that you know really
um relies uh falls to the north american
electric reliability council they they
are the reliability rule setter
um that's a national actually
international candidates included
national
uh standard setting body that has
enforceable rules
uh that can be enforced by very large
penalties we're subject to those rules
as well
uh we're not a regulator um we're more
the traffic cop the air traffic
controller of the power flow on the
system
uh and we don't you know set policy or
rules
uh we're you know really more in the
business of following them
uh than setting them
okay the next question related is from
the texas tribune
does ercot have a sense of how many
power plants or how much
generation capacity was weatherized
before this disaster
and of those plants did they remain
online during the storm
yeah so in theory all of them are
weatherized
to some extent and so that that's the
question is how
how well they were weatherized and i
think that's one of the things that
we're going to have to
look more at it did they trip because of
the lack of weatherization
we'll get that through this request for
information to find out
kind of what was going on there i think
that's definitely something we're going
to be looking at
and we've seen progress on
weatherization in the last 10 years
since the 2011 events
uh and you know generators have spent
you know time and resources
to uh prevent those sort of winter
related problems but
i'm sure those generators you know now
that they're able to get up and be back
in action or looking at uh what happened
uh that that caused them to trip out
during this time
and uh taking measures to to repair that
to address that
we're still in the winter you know so i
think the responsible generators are out
there looking and
uh fixing those things that can be fixed
to continue to operate at full capacity
when we have other events where we need
all hands on deck
okay and a follow-up question can you
explain if there were any other factors
other than lost generating capacity in
why the rolling outages were unable to
affect the role
uh the the main reason they were not
able to effectively roll but is that
the amount of demand that we had to
uh put into outage because of the
imbalance in supply and demand that
amount of demand was so
large that when we uh directed the
transmission companies hey we need you
know this number of megawatts
uh you know at one point it was up to 20
000 megawatts
on outage now the way you do rotating is
you have
a number of megawatts a number of health
household neighborhoods that you know
are going to be served that you need to
put an outage
and you can move those to different
parts of your service territory
uh this was such a large block that it
made it very difficult for the
transmission providers to
move them uh while they were still
needed
and so that it was harder to rotate them
so as the
number of road amount of rotating outage
or rather the
amount of megawatts that were needed uh
to balance supply and demand
diminished it was they could more easily
rotate but for most of the time
you know we were facing this crisis that
was really difficult for them to do
i think this is a probably a lesson
learned for the industry not just ercot
but but kind of internationally
that that there as we start to start to
now think through some of the process
improvements that need to be made
there's a lesson learned that that maybe
well nobody wants this to happen ever
because
we've seen the outcomes of it but maybe
you need to have a higher percentage of
your demand that's capable
of handling rotating outages
uh red because of the potential
although you try to avoid the potential
for for those kind of
massive low shed event you may need the
ability to
rotate more of your load rather than a
smaller amount that they were able to do
during this
and you're going to avoid it i mean it
is always a very difficult issue for the
transmission
providers who uh you know when when we
make that directive in order to keep the
grid safe and out of blackout uh we're
asking them to
execute it uh and the plans they make
have to be sensitive to you know you
don't want us to turn off circuits that
serve hospitals uh or other you know
critical care facilities
and so managing around uh
those critical care areas where you
really don't want to turn off power
you know leaves you less and less area
to to execute these when you have to do
them so
i think dan is saying it's it's
something that uh
i imagine people will look at having
seen an outage of this size
uh had to be edited while keeping you
know
uh aggressive you have to have critical
care
uh customers protected uh and then
you know how do you balance that out to
make sure you can do both
okay the next question is from texas
public radio
climate change is making extreme weather
events like the storm we saw this week
more probable
does ercot recognize this reality and
will it prepare for a storm even worse
than
when we just saw
well we do uh assessments
of what we expect in coming seasons um
and in that assessment uh we take a look
at
you know all the weather all the weather
data going back
and i think as we look at you know
having seen a storm that was
that so much enormously more
uh demand than had been uh
seen before that's that sort of set that
certainly sets a new standard and then i
think we'll be looking at those
uh uh estimation processes in general i
mean as we sort of go back and say you
know what what can we do to recognize
what we saw here uh and how should that
inform
the way that we provide the information
that we want to be you know as
as reliable as meaningful as possible
but also take into account
uh particular extremes i think we'll be
looking at a lot of different things
working with a park participant
uh to figure out those questions and
probably not just
us but also there are other industries
that
this is going to be a storm that that
apparently beyond like water systems the
natural gas system there's going to be a
need for all of them to consider
this kind of storm or beyond now that
we've seen that
this kind of thing can happen and how
can they reduce some of the outages that
they saw so
not only archive is the generation on
erica it's the water systems the
the natural gas system i think it's
going to be important for all of us
from what i've eliminated news reports
i've seen on this
have time to look at that that are going
to need to improve
okay next two questions are from the
dallas morning news
uh what percent of available natural gas
generation units were offline and what
percent
of available wind units were offline
yeah so i think we can we can answer the
part of that question and it was
roughly half of the installed capacity
uh for the natural gas we don't have the
different fuel types broken out at this
point but we
that question has been asked twice now
this morning and that will be something
we'll
uh as we start into more of the
investigation on this we'll try to break
that out and provide the numbers
lastly maybe as quickly as we can pretty
much
since you mentioned it why don't you
mention what installed capacity is but
it's all about
just capacity sure so the install
capacity of a
wind program is is kind of the amount
that if the wind was blowing kind of
full out the amount of
generation that it would be able to
produce typically though
from our capacity planning perspective
for a wind turbine we count about 30
percent of that capacity
because that's typically how much the
wind is blowing what percentage of the
power can be produced by a wind turbine
during peak conditions of from our
kind of future looking capacity
assessment so we're really not counting
uh we've got roughly 30 thousand
megawatts of wind
and we don't count all of that toward
meeting peak during the
conditions about a third of that
okay and their second question was did
some cities have to
increase the percentage of load shed
because other cities weren't able to
rotate
you know um i don't think we
have an answer for that uh because the
uh
those plans for how you conduct an
outage are are managed by the
transmission utilities
um and i i really don't think we can
speak to
how those were distributed amongst parts
of their territories some of their
territories have many cities in them
some of them are focused in one city
uh and we just really don't have any any
data on that
okay okay the next question is from
reuters
there are reports that wealthier areas
of dallas received power
while other areas faced outages can you
comment on that and can you detail
how decisions are made around which
areas and when go through
rotating outages
but i'd say similar to the last question
uh once we
direct that rotating outages neither
outages as we've seen here that aren't
rotating need to occur
to avoid a blackout and maintain system
security
we issue that directive that direction
to
uh the utility and then they manage
how the outages are distributed within
their area
so i i i don't couldn't speculate really
about uh exactly what
went on as far as the distribution of
those went um or
or what the details of those plans are
those plans are
put together by those utilities and and
they drill on them and execute them
so really they're the ones to speak to
that
okay the next question from jack howland
yesterday ercot officials mentioned the
winter of 2011 was used as a basis for
worst-case scenario limits
did ercon consider the impact climate
change could have on winter weather
making winters more severe than in the
past i
think i i don't know i thought we'd
address that i think we're um
uh looking at uh all the you know any
any number of scenarios
as we examine how uh our forecast
reports are put together
uh 2021 certainly puts a marker down
uh for the kind of severe weather that
we really had not seen
uh and that's we're going to have to
examine
you know everything about that and then
what implications
what we've seen has in the future
okay the next question texas railroad
commissioner wayne christian says
ercot failed to maintain a backup supply
of electric generation
what's your response
uh there there is not a backup supply of
generation
uh but that's really um
caused by the way our market is
structured
um the way the energy only market is
structured since the
i guess the passage of sd7 has been
called energy only
um it doesn't involve having a set of
units that you don't use except
in a backup type situation uh and i
think
uh you know what we were seeing
out on the system as the storm can was
say just about every generating unit
that could was running or wanting to run
and and you know that included backup
generation from some industrial
facilities that
uh put that power that usually is used
to run their systems on the grid
so there's not a a backup system
maintained by the state or maintained by
the generators
but that's been a part of the structure
of this market that
you rely on the generation that's out in
the system
uh and if it's sufficient uh you should
be able to meet your demand
well and then in this case because we
lost 40 of the general advanced
assistance you had to have a backup of
40
of your expected peak demand uh and that
would
um that's that's that's you that's not
even something that's been talked about
in the past i think
that that number has to be reduced we've
got to keep the generation available
and i just add too and i think
probably obviously what i was saying
earlier about the the efforts the
generators have made to get
the stuff fixed back up generation
wouldn't be
it would be just as vulnerable to the
weather damages that we saw if your
backup generation was gas
you might have gas supply issues you
might have mechanical issues caused by a
storm blowing through
if it was wind you have freezing
turbines it it
there's not there didn't seem to be with
this 2021 storm
any kind of generation that was uh
immune
from damage because of the the way this
came in
over the last week
okay the next question is from nbc
dallas
the governor said yesterday ercot failed
how do you respond to that comment
well i think the the uh assessment of
how we performed and you know how
everyone performed
in this event related to it is what
we're going to be looking at starting
next week
in the legislative hearings i think
that's something will be examined
when our regulators the nerc i mentioned
earlier nerc is certainly going to have
a full
examination of every step we took and
whether it complied with reliability
rules
and that process is starting and we
expect it to be
full throttle for quite a while because
you know this was absolutely a major
event
uh and i think the uh i just feel like i
do have to say that the
the certainly there are always things we
can do better
but the decision that the operators made
about 125
on you know sunday night monday morning
uh to protect the system given
uh the dire conditions that we're seeing
uh that's the decision
uh i'll defend and if if the failure is
in that
um i i
i guess we'd have to disagree i think
but i think if the failure was in other
areas certainly we'll talk about
you know anything that we did that we
can improve
okay uh next question some state
lawmakers
are saying the situation shows the state
needs to build more natural gas plants
what are dan and bill's response to that
well again i think as we start the
analysis and investigation process
uh there may be things that we that you
know people learn that indicate
uh various things about the the
resources that we have or the resources
that we ought to have
in our market system um ercot manages
the grid that
that is presented to us uh and that that
grid
that's driven by you know private
investment decisions
uh is composed of lots of different
kinds of generation
so i think as policy makers look at how
to avoid
an outcome like this in the future
certainly
there will be issues about you know all
aspects of the um
power system on the table and we're you
know obviously we'll participate in
those
discussions as much as they want us and
implement the rules they make
and and in this case the uh
uh the gas plants that remained online
and weren't you know that weren't
tripped offline either because because
of weather conditions
we're having trouble getting natural gas
for their
their plant and so if we had a higher
let's say percentage
of natural gas plants that we were
depending on there would
have to be a commensurate increase in
available gas
and since a lot of the problems with the
gas plants was all the way back to the
wellheads that were not weatherized
putting gas from the ground
into the pipes that then could be used
for heating and for these plants
there's going to have to be an increase
in in that process and in those systems
to make sure that you've got enough gas
for those increased number of plants so
it's it's a it's it's
interrelated and you have to solve but
you can't solve the problem just with
one thing you'd have to solve a problem
with multiple
uh ways of doing that if the
policymakers want us to go down that
path
okay the next question to what degree do
you think the events of last week are
the results of systemic
problems in how ercot runs the grid
namely there is not enough incentive for
backup power during weather events
i think you've sort of addressed that
but i'll let you respond directly to it
uh i i guess you know to sort of
pick up on what i was saying earlier
about the you know the structure of
senate bill 7 and the restructured
market
um it made you know generate
a competitive business took it out of
the old sort of monopoly regulation
framework
and you know very soon after that uh sb7
was passed by the legislature we saw a
dramatic increase in
uh capacity right i mean we saw new
capacity built
a lot of it was natural gas uh and i
think the competitive market
has driven investment decisions that
have given us
a generation fleet
that has managed you know the highest
summer loads the highest summer peaks
we've ever seen you know year after year
so there is there is generation on the
system
efficient to manage uh the loads that
we're seeing
i just have to say that the challenge
here was not so much that there wasn't
enough capacity
like i was saying earlier when we were
planning ahead for the storm
the capacity appeared to be sufficient
except in certain periods
where we saw the the generation or the
uh
the demand exceeding it like monday
morning and tuesday morning
but for the most part it was sufficient
what happened is
uh when that generation was not able to
supply you know 40 percent of the
generation that was planned
uh because of all the things associated
with the storm
uh that's what you know really caused
the issue
and so i don't know that i don't know i
agree there are insufficient investment
incentives
um for backup generation uh but
um i just think as you look at this
event so so much of it has to do with
this event and the sort of catastrophic
weather
and all it did uh to the power system as
dan said before you know to the road
uh to the water system and before we're
continuing to have many issues
okay the next question is from nbc in
dallas on monday morning
you went from a level two to level three
emergency in a matter of minutes can you
describe
what happened in those minutes what was
it like in your control center
and what exactly led to such a sudden
move from level two to level three
okay um i'll start i think the the
reason it moves so quickly
is that those levels are determined by
certain factors we're seeing on the
system so if you're in
energy emerald alert level one there are
certain things that trigger that
uh two and three are the same and there
are responses
that are triggered by those levels um
and
you know with rotating outages being the
last one in the energy or
alert level three uh energy emergency
level three
so uh what happened is you know we
declared the emergency we started the
processes for
getting the resources we needed using
the tools that are available to us in
that first
and second level but the the key issue
is around 11 o'clock that night
we saw a lot of the generation we've
been talking about coming off as the
storm really blew in
around that time and the there were so
many units that had to come off the
system so quickly
that the frequency was dropping very
quickly uh that drove us you know
into uh the energy emergency alert
levels
and it just kept moving very quickly i
mean that was really what it comes down
to is that we have to respond in real
time
to real things uh you know going out on
that are happening out on the system
and that's what was happening was we had
to go into eea
iii in fact the nerf rules that we
responded to or talked about before
that have to regulate us on reliability
issues you know demand that you take
those steps
and they should so that's why it went
fast
because the situation was extremely
fluid and moving very fast
as far as the environment in the control
room
you know people are obviously aware
highly aware you know when we have these
kind of conditions
uh the you know fortunately the control
room operators
remain calm in these situations they've
drilled on these situations
uh many of them are very experienced
that have been through difficult
situations on the grid that didn't have
nearly as you know
difficult uh outcome as this one but
certainly have had very big issues so
they remain pretty calm but they took
the steps they needed to take and they
weren't afraid to do them because they
knew the consequences of not doing them
so uh it wasn't like there were people
running around yelling and screaming and
people were
calm and doing their job do you have
anything to
no i think that's a good description all
right we were both there
so yeah you saw it different
uh okay the next question from salvador
cruz fernandez are customers still being
asked
to conserve power
now bill mentioned earlier that we've
moved out of emergency
operations as of i think it was 10 35
and so now that also removes the
conservation request i think at that
time
and we only request conservation from
customers when we really feel like we're
you know nearing emergency conditions we
put out a conservation request
sunday just because we knew the storm
was really coming in sunday night monday
and we discussed the need for
conservation at the at the press
conference at the state operations
center on saturday
just trying to get texans to realize you
know this was for real uh
and there really was a need to conserve
um and i don't know too i i want to
thank people who did
uh because even though you know the
conservation efforts
were not able to stop us from having the
event that came
because we lost so much of the supply
side
uh it can make a difference and it often
has made a difference when we've been in
you know tight conditions before
it can prevent us from having to go into
energy emergencies at all
so when we request it we do it sparingly
because we don't want to be crying wolf
with people
but when we request it we really do
appreciate when people take it up and
you know we heard from people who were
and
it's it's very much appreciated because
it makes a difference in how we can
manage difficult situations
probably reduce the amount of loads of
their neighbors
not their neighbors but other people in
other texans
the amount that we had to uh turn off to
make
yeah because we had this amount of
generation somehow we had to get load
down to that level
if people hadn't conserved we might have
had to turn off
more tech guns and that would have been
bad so we really
potential that did help a lot
okay the next uh request our question is
from maya shea from abc
13 in houston uh what do you say to
texans who have lost
family members homes and livelihoods
they are angry and they think her cut
should pay
also do you believe ercot should be
treated as a private company or a public
entity
uh as far as the first part um
you know we share the sadness and grief
that uh came to our state with this
event
uh certainly the electric outages were a
huge part you know before that we were
seeing wrecks on the highways with ice
or having water system issues certainly
it's just been a very very difficult
period for the state
uh and you know i think i think as far
as uh you know sugarcoat pay i guess
what i what i'd say to you is you know
we're gonna continue to try to explain
uh the event what we saw uh what we did
uh the actions we took
and uh you know as we're we're subject
to
um policymakers and leaders and you know
how they want us to operate
and if they're seeing that there's
something that's really got to change
uh from you know looking at the totality
of what we did
uh we'll certainly try to change it uh
or take any other action we're told to
do
to manage uh the issues that they're
seeing
is there a second okay uh no you you
covered them both
um thank you uh the next question
i'm not sure you can answer but i'll
read it i realize it's still early but
can you give us any sense of how much
an additional cost it would be for
generators to winterize their facilities
to the degree that would be needed to
withstand another extreme cold weather
event like the one we saw this week
yeah that's data we don't really have uh
we don't
run power plants or operate them we
don't winterize them
so it's not uh you know it's not a part
of the business that we go out and do
so i don't think we could really provide
anything uh
all that useful on that
okay uh the next question from
eva ruth moravec how does ercot
leadership
think the federal government responded
to this crisis was it sufficient
and or expected
um well uh
to be honest um i can tell you about the
federal response that that we were
engaged in
um i'm sure as this event has gone on
well we've been focused
on getting the power back on there have
been other other parts of this you know
the tragedy caused by the weather that
you might be referring to but i i don't
really have information on those
um we did ask the united states
department of energy for an emergency
order
uh that governor abbott encouraged us to
get out there and get i think especially
he and
senator cornyn were instrumental in
helping us achieve
very quickly i think basically within 24
hours
and what that allowed was for uh federal
rules to be uh set aside
just for the the time that we were in
emergency conditions uh and
which gave a lot of the uh or something
i don't know how many i don't know the
number we'll get that data as we
investigate
but uh generation units to run at full
power
uh if they were able so uh that
certainly was useful and we appreciate
the department of energy's
cooperation and making that happen and
making it happen extremely fast i know
our legal counsel our general counsel
was in conference calls at midnight 1am
uh working through the language on that
and getting it done and certainly
appreciate governor abbott his
administration and
pushing that through so that was helpful
uh
and so that was the main
federal involvement uh that
that we are aware of and the part of the
of the
process that we're involved in
okay the next question from the
montgomery county gazette can you uh
walk us through when you will be
presenting something
to the legislature regarding this event
yes there are two legislative hearings
one in the texas senate and one in the
texas house except for next thursday
so we will be presenting uh at both of
those hearings
okay the next question from texas
monthly
it seems that other states including
oklahoma and new mexico
suffered the same weather as texas but
with only a tiny fraction of the outages
is there something texas can learn from
those states about how to run a reliable
grid
you know honestly we haven't had the
time to to look much further than the
work we've had to do here
uh but uh we'll certainly investigate
what we're seeing all over the country i
think when our regulator the
nerc the reliability regulator comes in
uh certainly
it's something they'll look at but i
think if there's lessons learned from
any of our
neighboring power areas uh it's
something we'll certainly look at and
try to
improve from
okay i think you um may have addressed
this
but we're still getting questions so i
will ask it uh
since you were working off of a 2011 and
2018 emergency plan that failed
going forward how will you plan to have
enough cushion or reserve in a winter
storm to avoid this
i i guess let me back up a little bit
because when we talk about
2011 and 2018 2011 was when we
saw what's been the worst weather up
until this week winter weather
in texas and so we we sort of said it as
a marker for you know
well we know it can get this cold we
know we can see these kind of conditions
and then fed that into the you know the
computer models and everything that we
do
when we look at forecasting and planning
in 2018
we saw some very severe significant
weather
uh that year that rivaled uh
2011 that but we the system managed to
go through it
uh and we felt like you know some
improvements had been made
across the system since 2011 and were
encouraged by that
so it wasn't that there were um models i
guess or
market structures or anything that were
uh
you know 2011 and 2018 were not ways of
managing the system
um the system is managed according to
the law and regulation
federal and state uh and those
regulations are
you know updated at certain intervals
and we implement those
so i think we were operating the system
uh we believe according to
to those mandates uh and i don't think
there was really a 2011 or 2018
plan that i'm aware of that said any
different
okay next question when the governor
ordered the natural gas operators to
stop sending natural gas
out of the state how much impact did
that have on a comeback
uh that that's something uh
that we i think you probably need to
talk to the gas generators about because
those supplier relationships between the
gas
and the gas generators they're the ones
that are going to know
what they received i think certainly
opening up
more supply that the governor tried to
do uh
definitely could have had a significant
impact on the ability
of these generators who came back and
recovered and helped us get out of
emergency conditions
certainly could have helped them uh
absolutely but we we just don't have
the data to measure that
okay uh next question from matt degrood
what was the purpose of raising megawatt
prices
i know you said you hadn't seen evidence
generators were withholding
power but did you all search for
evidence of that
raising megawatt right well i guess i'll
start in with
um the with the the wholesale pricing
this isn't
detailed you know end-user customer
pricing but the way the wholesale
pricing of power works in our
generally is uh that we pay more
when we have scarcity conditions so
uh on a day when there's no scarcity
whatsoever
prices will be lower but as the
conditions get tight
and we realize you know we're needing
more uh
power on the system then the the
computer systems that run this are
programmed to automatically send out a
new price signal
uh that says this is what you'll get
paid if you if you produce now
uh and so uh plants that are
not wanting to run at one price level uh
will wait for that
other price signal to tire and then
they'll come on uh and
and i think when the public utility
commission is set up the
uh the rules for how scarcity pricing
works and evolve them over time
uh they've seen that you know when we
get to
the higher levels of scarcity pricing
it's very effective
uh because you know not only do the
generators pay attention because there's
an incentive to do so but
they pay attention because if you uh if
you say you're going to produce at that
price
and you don't um there's significant
financial consequences for it
so that scarcity pricing mechanism is is
what we sort of rely on generally
and so as you see those prices in the
wholesale market get higher it's
you know usually going to be related to
the fact that we have tight conditions
and that's the incentive we want to make
sure people have to respond
okay next question a state lawmaker says
these
issues aren't new we saw them in 2011.
how hard will you and urcot push to make
sure changes are made to keep this from
happening again
well we do not want this to happen again
and uh any effort whether you know
wherever it happens
we're uh happy to participate in
figuring out solutions that keep us from
this sort of thing um the the
fundamental physical fact that you do
not
want your uh you know damson saying you
know your supply and demand to get too
out of balance
so you and avoiding a blackout that can
last weeks
months you know we don't really know how
long it all depends on the conditions
that
get uncontrolled that's a fundamental
tenet
because it's just too difficult uh to
try to repair one of those if you don't
have to you have controls that can keep
it from happening
so i think that's you know going to be a
fundamental objective but then
i think this this uh phenomenon we saw
here
of you know having to reduce demand such
that
as we've talked about outages couldn't
rotate because the number of outages
was as large as it was to contain the
problem i think that's certainly
something that
people need to be creative including us
be creative and think about
uh how to manage that because that was
one of the big challenges here in texas
was
you know we had told people about
rotating outages but
then they couldn't rotate and then it's
like well what's going on here and
that's certainly part of the frustration
and difficulty of it but until that
number of megawatts have been
uh you know put an outage uh it wasn't
clear that that was going to be a
problem but once
once the transmission providers had to
implement it it was a very big problem
okay the next question is from eleanor
with the fort worth star telegram
governor greg abbott has called on state
lawmakers to mandate the weatherization
of power generators
is this something ercon supports and
what specific measures would you all
like to see
implemented for weatherization
i think it was a really productive step
to get the legislature to direct the
legislature encourage them to look at
that
right away on an emergency basis because
we have been through
an extraordinarily difficult we're still
going through in
in through texas uh in the power water
and
in all these areas extraordinary
emergency situation and it's worth
getting on the question of how do we
prevent this in the future right away so
i think suggesting that we look at those
weatherization rules the great idea
i think the specific measures um it kind
of comes back to
we're talking about earlier questions
where we don't run power plant
we don't pretend to know what's the best
thing to do
in a particular kind of wind turbine gas
turbine
nuclear plant uh there are experts in
that and they work at the power plants
in texas
uh those are the ones who got out in the
middle of the night
and fixed the plants and got us back in
business so i think really um you know
working with uh those folks uh on
who have the expertise on the specific
measures that that part you ask about
i think is really uh you know a good
place to look um
and determine you know what makes the
most sense
okay uh another follow-up from texas
monthly
had there been a full blackout of the
sort ercot was working to avoid
what would the procedure have been for
resuming power
from that please walk us through the
steps that would have been involved
i'm going to let dan handle that it's a
process called black start
and i'll tell you that we have never had
to do it in texas uh
it had to be done in other regions um
but i'll let them
walk through our process on it and so so
uh
we actually although we absolutely hope
that never happens we actually have a
plan in place to restart the system if
it ever went black and and and actually
we drill on that plan
with the transmission operators and
generation operators once a year
um so it would be
very painful as bill's been saying but
if there is a plan to do it and it
regards it starts with starting up
diesel generators at
specific power plants around the state
those are used then to energize
lines or to certain other
power plants and then gradually adding
load
customers around the power plant
starting to energize transmission lines
adding customers around power plants and
building it out from each of these uh 12
sites around the state starting to build
out
and if there's a whole lot of switching
of transmission lines has to go on you
have to open
all the breakers in a substation and
then close in on a particular path
close in another path ultimately
over time you link all 12 of these
islands
together and then once you get those you
have to
to open other lines and start to
add more load back and add more
generation back and it's
just an incredibly uh
difficult process and takes time
and at all points in time you're having
to
as balanced as you add each generator
back you're adding
you're adding load you've got a inch
up inch up inch up and maintain that
balance all the time so the generators
don't trip offline and what we've seen
in some of the simulations
is that what what happens there'll be a
go back
you'll actually start to build the
system back and then that
island will trip back out and then you
have to go
inch back up again and gradually you get
the whole system built back
but uh and there are other things that
will trip generators out too you've got
to maintain the voltage on the system
and i'm
kind of being a nerdy engineer here but
that that
is to describe the just how difficult
that is and uh it's a process
although we have a plan for it just in
case we don't ever want to do it
and it requires you know a lot of
personnel being out at places and doing
physical connections
and doing all this when the power's not
on and it's icy in this case
and it's icy in this case if we had had
to start that process
this week so it's uh
yeah it's not a simple process but there
is one
and again that's why we drill on it in
case we ever get into that situation but
that's exactly the kind of thing we
wanted to avoid you know
early monday morning yeah
uh from mark watson at platts how low
did the frequency dip on monday morning
he saw that it might have gone as low as
59.3
it was a hair above 59.93 yeah
59.3 i'm sorry 59.00 sorry
59.33 or 32 or something like that
and it's supposed to be at 60 and
there's not a very big tolerance
it isn't it's not like it was at 60 well
why didn't you just let it go to 30.
like what you might explain actually
like 50 you said 593 is low
let's put that sentence in the context
about what would have happened if
they've gone to 59.1 or 58 yeah
if if that frequency goes down too far
then generating units aren't designed to
operate at those low frequencies and so
that
if you get let that supply imbalance the
generator start tripping loads up here
generator stuff maybe off the field
generators start tripping load uh you
have to get the load down to that level
and keep it
balanced as generators continue to shred
if that frequency gets too low
that in it of itself actually causes
more generators to trip on
which the frequencies go lower and more
generator script it's what's called the
cascade
so uh there is a safety net where some
of that load shed would have happened
automatically but if you continue to
lose generators or
uh you lose too much potentially too
fast
before that automated load shed happens
uh
it the safety net might not have taught
us
the other thing is you know 59.3 is uh
low but it's fed there because of the
you know the speed of the activities we
were seeing just like the question
earlier about why did we go into energy
emergency alerts so fast it was
the dynamics of the system were shifting
so fast with this horrendous weather
coming in
generators dropping off and as the
weather came in the load continuing to
increase
so it was that you know combination of
things that were going very quickly that
took it down there but that's when they
had to act and
ultimately as i said earlier as
generation trips offline
that's all the load we can serve there
is nothing we you can do
to serve more load if that's all the
supply you've got so as supply continued
to decrease as these generators tripped
off
you can't it's just it's physics you
can't serve more loads than
the amount that of generation that's
available on the system
and so for whatever reason these
generators were dripping offline we
talked a lot about the reason
you still can't serve more loads than
the amount of supply you've got it's
just
it's physically impossible and so uh
regardless of what the mechanism is by
which the load gets whether it's us
doing it in a controlled way the way we
did whether it's the safety net tripping
the load off
or whatever you're going to get down to
the level that
you've got generation to serve it and
for as long as you only have that amount
of generation
you can't serve more loads and so that's
really
part of the problem i mean it's kind of
like
you know if you said you know you plan
to take a 50 mile drive
the gas you had in your car would only
get you 10. you're taking a 10 mile
drive
i mean that that's so if we had if i
mean
if we had done nothing when we saw that
much generation come off
we would have tripped into these all
these problems dan's talked about
uh but you know if we'd done nothing uh
there still would have been an enormous
amount of outages
you know because because if if the only
available generation
at that point in that night was i don't
know say
45 000 megawatts i'm not that don't
quote me on the number but
if it was that much then we could serve
demand up to 45 000 megawatts but the
demand was much higher
so one way or the other you know if
everybody was hooked up if all the lines
weren't right as all the consumers were
in but man would have been much higher
yeah so it that that's that's a limit on
the system
okay uh we're about at 11 30
so i think what i'll do is i'll just go
ahead and try to ask maybe two more
questions and then bill if you want to
make any final remarks before we
conclude that call
i will uh turn it over to you for that
um
the next question that i'm seeing is
depending on what you find in those
rfi investigations who has regulatory
power to take action on the findings
yeah um
i i think we'll have to i i don't know
that there is any one if it depends on
what the finding is i guess
if there if there are things the north
american electric reliability council or
nerf
has certain uh uh regular has lots of
reliability standards for all the
different operating entities
in the in the electric system generators
transmission owners archive
uh all have to meet and so if there's
some uh something that happened that was
in violation of one of those standards
then
dirk and the federal energy regulatory
commission would
have a regulatory authority over that if
there's something that
folks did that was in violation of the
ercot protocols
that would be the public utility
commission
in the legislature that would have kind
of a regulatory oversight over
things that are violations of protocols
and so
i think those are the two real entities
there well i should add two
since we're talking about requests for
information rfi
we ask those to get information too i
mean not not
it's not so much to find violations on
our part because
when there's events like this there are
market participant groups
made up of experts many of which have
tons of experience particularly in our
market
and we take these event analysis to them
and they're even more technical than
he's talking today
and go into tremendous detail about what
we saw so
that you know people rely on us to have
they have the ability to gather
everyone's information
and when it's confidential keep it
confidential but still be able to make
these examinations
and do the lessons learned and you know
we participate in that but
uh we have market participants who are
generators transmission providers retail
providers
all across the board who are meeting
regularly
in you know difficult times and good
times you know because the market
continues to shift and evolve and
we really rely on our relationships with
them to develop
uh better practices so as dan's saying i
mean if
if information ends up being a violation
of a federal or state standard well
that's something somebody has to deal
with from the federal or state standard
but we're gonna we want the information
anyway because it built the data
set that lets us do analysis and make
the kind of improvements
that we've been talking about
okay i may ask two more um
what is the distinction between ending
the rotating outages and ending
emergency operations
what does returning to normal operations
mean
uh there are certain things we ask for
when we are in an emergency level one
for example
that are not rotating out of it uh
basically the way the energy
emergency alert levels work is
you're getting down into you know could
be a dangerous position
and so you do think we have we have
programs where
uh there are certain entities that uh
receive a payment
to take their load off voluntarily
right called emergency response service
and when we give them the call
when we're in an energy emergency alert
level two uh
then they're obligated and there's big
penalties they don't
they're obligated to come off the system
voluntarily to help
you know get the supply and demand
balance there's something called load
resource
which again is another uh demand side uh
set of resources that
uh we bring take off the systems
uh and so each one and requesting
conservation for example is
an eea level uh request so there are
things that we do
instantaneously once we get into one of
those levels
and and often you know we've been in eea
one before and then dropped back
we've been in ea ii before and dropped
back into regular operations so
they really do help resolve problems
before you get into the worst outcome
uh but that's sort of the structure of
how it goes
and i know there was a second part of
that one that i'm not getting
i think the question was what what does
it mean to return to normal
operations yes that's it so when we talk
about normal operations we're not asking
for any of those
uh out of market you know responses like
we need you to conserve or
we're going to we want you to
voluntarily reduce your load or
all of those mechanisms are tools uh
they're tools that we have in place for
when we need them to try to protect the
system
and so we're basically saying we think
the conditions now are like they were a
week ago
like they were two weeks ago where
you're not noticing anything about your
electricity because the system is stable
a generation is able to serve at the
level demanded by
demand or load and you know there's
there's nothing to see here there's
nothing we're asking people to do and in
ordinary operation
um well i should add i want to be sure
to add as dan just pointed out
in ordinary we're we're still having
people return to service
right we are not asking for additional
load shed we're not asking for
additional measures but just to be sure
i'm clear
the transmission providers out there who
are getting people back in the service
are still at work
at work on restoring the last of the
rotating outages that are still out as
well as working on things that had
nothing to do with rotating outages but
were storm damage you know like
ice or other other issues so i want to
be real clear on that
it doesn't mean that part's over that's
still underway but
typically in ordinary operations what we
mean is ercot as
the grid operator is not asking people
to do these things to protect the
integrity of the grid so really what
goes on most the time is we are
watching the balance of the system and
managing issues as they come up like you
know if a transmission line goes out of
service
we have to readjust uh how the
electricity is flowing we're working
with them on that
uh if a generating unit that's this
large drops off
and threatens the balance even though it
may not threaten entire reliability
we work on that and how to replace that
so we're constantly you know 24 7
managing
various types of issues on the system uh
and they're with
generation they're with load like for
example one of the ones we've been
challenged with over the past 10 years
now is intermittent resources that are
different than other resources on the
system
uh you know we've had to learn how to
balance with some resources that are on
and then off and then on and we can't
really control them like you can
a traditional you know machine like a
coal plant or a
nuclear or gas plant so constantly not
monitoring measuring doing all those
things but most days
it's completely in the background
uh because the system is stable
everybody's doing what they need to do
and the transactions that
manage the market are private
transactions in a marketplace
uh where people uh you know have profit
motives where
people are limited by the things we need
to serve the system
uh so i mean that's basically why you
know you you really only hear from us if
uh the general public only hears
about ercod if it's uh bad news uh
because
we're the ones who do have to step in
and direct that things happen
to make those worse things not happen
and
so that's what we did this week now that
we're in
ordinary operations we're hoping that we
stay there
for quite a while and we can just manage
the challenges on the system that exist
every day
but not manage the kind of challenge
that had such a cataclysmic effect as
as we've seen all over the state and
continue to see
uh this week
okay well thank you bill and dan and i
know several of you have messaged me
about wanting to see those
operations messages that have been that
that went out prior to the storm hitting
if you go to the home page of the ercot
website ercot.com
and then you scroll down to the bottom
of the page you'll see a market
communication
button and down there you can select
operations
messages and from there you can pull up
all of the
messages and notices that we sent out
prior to
this event hitting us so um
i think with that we will conclude this
call and we
appreciate you taking the time to uh
listen in
and i i think bill might have one one
more final remark so bill
i'm sorry i didn't interrupt i just
since since we're um emerging from
emergency operations
i think this will be the last of these
updating calls uh
and i just like to personally thank
everybody who has participated in
watching these
like everything else you know how we
communicate uh we'll be subject to
review
and discussion uh and if we haven't done
that effectively i mean certainly that's
certainly on us
but i really appreciate everybody who's
taken the time to get these updates i
hope they provided you useful
information as we've worked through this
crisis
uh and hoped it's made it you know at
least more understandable if not more
acceptable
uh that we've been in this and so just
want to thank everybody
uh for keeping up with this and as we
try to keep the public informed
so thanks
all right thank you all very much and uh
this will conclude our call
thank you
you